oh mike
yeah so i can hear what you're saying
i got that country boy accent yeah i
like it right your accent is what's sold
huh you thought it was your beard that i
liked i like your accent
i told you it was a hillbilly
oh well this hillbilly's got an accent
you live out in the country you got an
accent
you call yourself a hillbilly
i am
what makes you a hillbilly
well
go to school learn
work on a farm
stuff like that
what was your childhood like
oh my childhood is grown up go to school
come home work
kids got made today they get presents
back then we didn't
all we know is get up in the morning
work
go to school and come back work some
more
where you were born
54.
tell me about your mom and dad
my dad he was a coal miner for 30 years
till he went to advanced security
and my mother
she didn't do much but housekeeping
how would you describe your childhood
oh
it's not a childhood any child would
let food anymore
what do you mean by that
you have to work every day except
sundays
you guys went to church
yes we did
we
went uh morning worship and church
and on
saturday evenings we went to bible
studies
presbyterian church
tell me about your parents well my dad
he uh besides
he like uh
moonshine he made moonshine and then he
went uh
to uh
shoot hunting jinxing fishing he taught
me all that
but my grandfather
he taught me
how to make herbs
make medicine cough medicine other
with the herbs
you find in the woods yeah
a lot of things have changed now with
the new generation of kids right yeah i
don't know
and
adam for apple
only they think is that what's on a
telephone or
or a
laptop
what do you make of the new generation
of kids and especially here in
appalachia there's a lot of a lot of
drugs going around uh
okay
you want my really serious opinion about
they lazy
worthless
untrustworth worthy
and they
don't care who about anyone else but
there's help they get that fix every day
or that bought a big can of beer in
their hand
was alcohol everything for you or drugs
no i like i told i said
i don't drink and i don't do drugs
have you been married
once
she was killed by a drunk
when did that happen
long time ago
in my uh
mid-20s
she was killed by
a pill popping uh
george dickle drinker
hair head on and killed her on impact
i'm sorry
you have children
do you have kids
five
two boys three girls
how are they doing now
they doing
well
they uh
my oldest one is a boy
he uh he's a state trooper and he also
in the marine corps
he does a marine corps part-time does
two tours and come back
so does my son he's in the army
the other son
and my
daughter
oldest one
she
excuse me
she
is a federal uh
lawyer
and my own is a nurse
my youngest one is a school teacher
you raise your kids i raised my kids on
my own on your own without your wife
without their mother for most of it
without their mother
i might be a little hard on them
but it it paid off
that sounds like it
do you love living here in appalachian
no
tell truth
i did but now the way things are i don't
is that because of the people
that and some of the laws they got and
they don't uphold all the laws they
write that pass
and today you're living where
under a bridge
why are you living under a bridge
because that's the only
place i could sleep
without
getting disturbed or robbed or beaten
but without without a drug or alcohol
addiction
why would you
lose your home
uh that's a long story
it's a long story
i
went when my girlfriend died back in
2013
i drifted
stayed to state
and
he got to where point i just don't i
didn't like it
anymore i just
other states
like virginia
down there the sheriffs down there
they keep on trucking they won't let let
you stop
rest or get something to eat nothing
how did your girlfriend die
she died
her stems and our heart
failed
sorry
so just your
your depression or your mental state
that
led you into this situation
i don't know why i went crazy or not
that i could not answer
until i took a psych test
they find
i said until i take a sip oh until you
take one i see
you think there might be something
mentally going on with you that uh
i don't know i was gonna get all that
checked out
i was trying to get my id back
my everything i got back
then
then i'm gonna
start with my health
because i owe a lot of money out you do
who do you have money too
verizon
almost ten thousand to them
oh 184 to the housing
i owe the city 1340
for pines
i will water cut me almost at 800
dollars
i'll sanitation company
life is expensive isn't it
it is now
are your kids aware of your situation
yes they are
they help me much as they can
you have any regrets in your life
yes i have a few
if i can go back and change them i'll
change
i made one serious mistake in my life
and i'd like to change i wouldn't change
that one if i could
can i ask what that was
about strong armed robbery oh is that
right
did you get some prison time
twelve and a half years
were you trying to pay off some debts
yes i'm trying to pay everything i owe
out but is that why you
tried the robbery
yeah yeah
do you have any friends
i don't call them friends i'll call them
associates
what was the best what were the best
years of your life
my best year
none
what's been the worst time of your life
my worst time
when i got shot in a leg
who shot you in the leg
a married man
you were involved with his wife his
girlfriend
not his wife but his girlfriend
his girlfriend
he had a wife but i was messing with his
girlfriend
it's complicated
yeah i told you there are strange things
in my life yes
and living homeless under the bridge
that must be dangerous right
it is what kind of stuff happens to you
there
nothing
nothing yet
that i can't handle
i mean how do you handle i mean what
kind of stuff happens and how do you
handle
it like i told you i have that taser
tell me about your taser
it's a
hand teacher put on your hand like a
brass knuckles
and
when opponent guy you get close enough
to opponent where you can sense through
metal
or anything it goes uh
go through
six thousand hd
that'll slow somebody down
and put i put them to ground
for about 15 20 minutes
what are you afraid of at this point in
your life
i don't fear nothing
what emotions do you go through
you get depressed or angry or
i get angry every once in a while but
i'm frustrated
but i never been depressed
are you lonely
i've been alone
since 2013.
you have siblings
your brothers and sisters
uh once in 11 i got two sisters and a
brother left out 12.
how are they doing
i haven't seen them in the last 30 years
oh really
would you call yourself a loner
i'd like to be alone
how was living on the streets affected
you how's it changed
it taught me a lot of things how many
years
almost nine years
it's changed you how
made me look smarter and wiser
in a lot of ways
do you feel like life is unfair
well sometimes
most time i don't
you still have hope of
finding a better life
i'll find a better life
because i don't have that much more time
on this planet
i can go anytime between now and then
you're 68 right
we'll be 68.
what personality trait do you possess
that helps you survive
it's just like uh what's that saying
my dad said
you don't do it
you never get it done
i go and do it do it yourself
man i know we get done
because
like i
think earlier
when we met
uh
i was waiting on a guy to go work thin
but he didn't show up when he said he
was
if you had your life to live all over
again what what kind of things would you
have done differently
one thing
committing that crime is one thing
two a few things i've done and said
otherwise
how often do you talk to your with your
kids now
i get to see my kids
two or three times a month
especially my boys
did you have role models when you were a
young man
no
what about your dad
i put this way
i love my dad as a dad
no better no look worse
they toss and uh
bible class
the sixth commandment
honor your father and mother
and billy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
there are several
one
when you go against a person
don't go head on on
two
don't take somebody lightly
all right billy thank you so much for
sharing your story okay i wish you the
best of luck out there
you